anouk poulet entame la 6e journée de sa
nouvelle vie dans un ch et celle des
l'architecte est devenu assistant du
préposé à un moment donné j'étais tanné
tourner en rond je me sentais comme un
lion dans une cage j'avais besoin de de
bouger puis j'avais besoin de changer de
groupe
j'avais besoin d'être au front dès que
je franchis la porte du vestiaire
l'odeur d'uriné d'excréments et de
désinfectants me pognon ni même avec le
masque la bénévole lit son journal de
bord qu'elle a publié sur facebook un
texte poignant qui raconte aussi ses
coups de coeur pour les bénéficiaires à
qui elle donne des surnoms
il y à monsieur don juan madame coquette
ses cheveux sont fins doubs salue aussi
elle m'explique que ça fait cinq
semaines qu'elle n'a pas pris de bain je
vérifie plus tard auprès d'une préposée
et c'est vrai l'heure des repas est une
mission impossible
il manque de personnel pour nourrir tous
les patients j'ai passé trente minutes
avec elle et j'ai eu l'impression de la
pressée j'ai trois autres passées à
nourrir je fais un rapide calcul
mathématique et je sais déjà que 22
patients
une préposée une assistance sans
expérience ça me fait peur quand les
anecdotes que je raconte ses débours
moment
que j'ai eu avec certains patients mais
au détriment d'autres ça allez un petit
peu avec ma naïveté le fait que choix
naïve nouvelle je prenais le temps
d'être avec s'est passé en lots mais
pendant que la préposée elle la stat et
toutes les autres le plus difficile
c'est de ne pouvoir répondre à tous les
patients qui appelle à l'aide
pour aller aux toilettes par exemple les
dégâts se multiplient il n'arrête pas de
répéter sa statue je m'excuse mais non
monsieur dangereux ça va tous nous
arriver il faut s'entraîner c'est tout
ce que j'ai trouvé à dire pour sauver sa
dignité
la mienne aussi mais je pense linverse
noi
ça n'arrivera jamais plutôt mourir
parfois les émotions se bousculent s'est
passé défilent dans mon cerveau pour le
rassurer le protégé j'ai mal au dos
comment nettoyer par quoi commencer et
surtout faut pas que je vomis si le
premier soir quand je suis revenu chez
moi je me rappelle il a fallu que je
parle à une amie à moi qui est médecin
puis m expliquer que je pleurais j'avais
dit des sanglots pm10 et le choc c'est
normal puis par exemple choc et chaos
c'était la semaine dernière l'arrivée
des militaires a beaucoup aidé c'est
déjà en forme dynamique y perdre il est
enfin que ça fait une grosse différence
on ne double il ratio
au préposé préposé versus bénéficiaires
le journal de bord de la bénévole fait
fureur sur facebook
14000 partage et des milliers de
commentaires
pour moi ces messages d'amour l'eau
devra lui proposer parce que moi j'écris
ce texte l'eau après trois jours de
travail
puis ces gens là sont là depuis deux ans
cinq ans 29 petits pire mais ça jamais
été rose dans les chu celtique soit
encore lopy avec tout leur coeur à nos
poulains souhaite que la reconnaissance
que les préposés ont enfin obtenu
survival épidémie ici sophie langlois
radio canada montréal